a state-like funeral for a journalist
who dedicated her life to the struggle
for freedom
sherina barclay was killed by israeli
soldiers on wednesday but the veteran
journalist's legacy will live on
while she was alive she was an icon in
the arab-speaking world
and by murdering her israel has now
ensured her name has transcended even
its own militarized checkpoints and
borders
reaching people the world over okay we
were standing here for an hour nobody
talked to us
born in 1971 shireen grew up under the
harsh reality of an illegal occupation
that continues to strip millions of
palestinians from their most basic
rights
[Music]
it was her quest for freedom that drove
her to eventually pursue a career in
journalism
chirin had initially studied civil
engineering as per her parents wishes
but her determination to seek the truth
to manifest her freedom through
journalism and to speak truth to power
was too strong
she switched careers and eventually
graduated with a degree in print
journalism from the al-jarmook
university in neighbouring jordan
she began her professional career
working for the united nations refugee
agency onorwa before moving on to the
voice of palestine and then france's
monte carlo radio station
as a relatively unknown 26 year old
shireen joined al jazeera shortly after
the channel launched
she's seen in this clip with jerusalem
bureau chief foreign
her to the audience
both unaware of the impact she would go
on to have both in life and death
sharina quickly became a household name
through her coverage of the second
intifada and the crimes committed by the
israeli occupation during its invasion
of ramallah and surrounding cities in
the early 2000s
speaking calmly yet confidently her
distinctive voice relayed stories from
the refugee camps the illegal
checkpoints and even from inside
israel's prisons the more she reported
the more israeli forces and settlers
tried to silence her but she never lost
her composure nor her determination
beyond palestine shillin also reported
from cairo london new york and other
cities around the world
she wasn't just a mentor to young girls
and boys who watched her on their
screens
the veteran reporter also taught
journalism at beers university
empowering youth through education and
providing young people living under a
brutal occupation with some hope that
their voices will one day be heard
sharing dedicated her life to giving a
voice to the voiceless
her silenced voice must now be amplified
by press freedom advocates to bring her
killers to justice
her body may be buried but sharing about
his name shall live on
foreign